Hi! My name is Lucas and I like to fly hang gliders.
Because that's what inspires me.
It's like the sky is my canvas and there's no lines to color between.
You're free to travel wherever the air can take you.
I use invisible masses of rising air to go up,...
...and then glide very long distances.
And I like to share this inspiration through creating videos and maybe inspire others.
My computer is pretty important for that.
And it allows me to do special effects, which is why I like superhero movies.
But I'm not defined only by my actions,...
...whether it's hang gliding, running, creating videos,...
...or even climbing three of the world's seven summits,...
...but also by my thoughts, beliefs, and most importantly, friends and family;...
...especially the one my wife and I just started together.
We have two awesome dogs.
Life is an adventure.
I love it.